Elizabeth is in Buffalo New York hi
Elizabeth how are you I'm good how are
you better than I deserve what's up in
your world
well I'm finishing a nursing program
this May so I'll have my RN when I
graduate good for some thank you I
already have a bachelor's degree that I
am obviously not using sign back in
nursing school and now like I can get a
job with the two-year degree but
eventually sometime in the future like
hospitals want you to have your BSN so
I'm already sitting on about like
$18,000 from my from my first degree in
student loan so I'm wondering since I'm
going to need it eventually anyway if I
should just like continue on with the
BSN program so you just called Dave
Ramsey and asked him to go deeply into
debt you just did that in front of
everybody did you realize that what I
know is what he's going to tell we brung
it up anyway
well I mean why why do you ask anyway
because it's real simple no I wouldn't
tell you to go into student loan debt
you got your freaking are in you're very
employable go get six jobs as a nurse
work ER on the weekends get the freakin
student loan debt paid off save up the
money to do the graduate work and then
go back with cash and do the graduate
work you knew I was going to say that
and you knew that's what you were
supposed to do I mean are you if you got
a love affair with Sallie Mae stop this
stuff people this is the Dave Ramsey
show thanks for joining us America it's
a free call triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2 5 you
know it is sad you know why we have a
student loan crisis because now people
it is so normalized that people almost
feel like they're doing something wrong
if they get a degree without student
loan debt and and the money is just too
accessible it's too easy to get it's
causing people to make stupid but
decisions if it was harder to get you'd
have to find out other ways to get this
done
Wow then you'd have a good idea you'd
have other ways to get this done and you
know once you take borrowing money as a
possibility off the table that's not an
option
don't call me and ask me to freakin
borrow money none of you there's 8
million of you listen real careful don't
call this show and ask me if it's okay
with me
if you borrow money I can give you the
answer freaking no it's real easy your
situations not different no no it's a
stupid but idea to go into debt to buy a
car
it's a stupid but idea to go into debt
to be a student
it's a stupid but idea to go into debt
to buy a steak dinner tonight on your
MasterCard and if you want to win with
money you've got to make the decision
I'm not going to be in debt you got to
finally decide because your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and people walk through this life
with you know three or four boat anchors
tied around their neck and can't figure
out why they can't swim I mean you're
walking around carrying eighteen
thousand twenty thousand sixty thousand
ten thousand five thousand and student
loan debt and and credit card debt and
car payments and you can't figure out
why you can't get ahead financially it's
cause you're giving all your freaking
money to the bank that's why you can't
get ahead you are a rat stuck in a wheel
so don't call me and ask me if it's okay
with me if you borrow money the answer
is no and the reason it's not okay with
me is not because I'm some nut burger or
not because I'm upset or something like
that it's because it freaking doesn't
work it doesn't work you're just going
to be normal and normal in America sucks
you pull up at a traffic light looking
good and all I see you're 610 dollar car
payments and you look stupid you don't
look good it's big hat no cattle your
whole freakin life is a facade you're
buying crap you can't afford with money
you don't have to impress people you
don't really like and to do things you
know the adult that is deep down inside
of you knows that you shouldn't be doing
don't do it don't do it if you do not
have the money do not buy the item wow
that was insightful if you don't have
the money you can't afford it in cash in
full not how
much down not how much a month not I've
got this great deal not I've got a
student loan reimbursement program not I
hope someday the government will bail my
butt out because I'm too stupid to do it
for myself none of that crap if you
don't have the money you can't afford it
that's how this works and it gives you
great peace of mind cuz here let me just
take can you breathe this in for a
second just breathe this in
what if you had no payments no student
loans no MasterCard no car payments what
have you even had no mortgage payment
think about how much money you would
have to give and to live stopped at
America this is stupid
you